And now to you, Scoutmaster.
Hello, it's Todd Grady, Scoutmaster with Troop 875 in San Augustine, Florida.
Did you hear about the fire in the sporting goods store?
It was intense.
Get it
Intense.
That's it Bye.
Wow,
Yeah,
Hey, this is podcast 103..
Hey, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Well, thank you, Todd, for calling in Todd Grady with a joke.
You can do it too.
I'll let you know before the end of the podcast.
It's a pretty fun experience, wouldn't you say
It was intense.
Get it.
Yeah,
All right,
And we're going to move right on ahead, because I have an installment of Scoutmaster
ship in seven minutes or less. that's less than seven minutes,
And I am so excited-
I'll bet you are too,
Especially if you're amongst the people who have been prescribed to listen to the
podcast by some civil authority,
And you must.
Well, this one is less than seven minutes,
Yep.
And then we've got a great email question that came in this week
And I think I'm going to change.
I was considering changing the title of that section to long answers to short
questions.
Oh well, listen, we're going to record a Scoutmaster's panel discussion very soon.
I'd like to have you be a part of it so you can call or email with your
question or your comment, that or a topic suggestion for discussion,
And you'll find out how to do that just at the end of the podcast. but we got
plenty of other things to do before we get there,
So let's get started.
Scoutmaster ship. in seven minutes or less
It's a clinker.
Now hands up everyone who knows who. that was
Very good.
Yes, I see you in the back there,
Of course.
That was Darren Mcgabbin in the movie the Christmas story.
His character, the dad in the in the movie, does battle with the coal
furnace.
If you burn coal for heat you can come up with clinkers, and clinkers are
kind of like this concretion of Coke- not the drink or the drug, but just a
byproduct of burning coal-
And it can block up the coal grate and it can put the fire out.
And I thought, wow. first of all, I love the movie and I want to have
sounds from it.
I like Darren Mcgabbin, you know. so that was one reason to use this.
The other reason was: is that just that's a really good illustration
for some things that we hear every once in a while.
We might call them urban legends,
We might call them, you know, something like that.
But every once in a while you come across something in a
conversation or as you're going along and scanning. it just
doesn't sound right.
Here's an example:
A couple of scouts were discussing doing a skit and a
leader.
I overheard a leader say to them: no, that skit's been
outlawed by national
And bing that was. that was a bit of a clinker,
I mean. I, you know, I try and keep up with this stuff
And I don't think that the National Council of the
Boy Scouts of America outlaws skits, especially specific
ones.
So here's what happened,
And you know, this happens all the time.
Somebody gets a little piece of information or makes a
little jump of logic
And then they come up with the idea that oh, oh well,
I think maybe this happened,
Or I think maybe that happened,
Or maybe they hastily read something.
I'm guilty of doing this,
You are too.
I'm guilty of all of this, by the way.
So this is not meant to be kind of a judgmental
pronouncement, but this is meant to just talk about
this sort of thing.
Okay,
Just let's talk about this sort of thing,
Not any specific policy related statement.
I'm talking about talking about them.
Is this getting confusing?
I apologize if it is, but so what happens is
is we'll read something quickly, or we'll read something
and we'll walk away with a certain understanding of it,
And then we'll go out and we'll start talking it around
and then you know what happens. right,
It's whispered down the lane,
Somebody else hears it, and then somebody else
hears it and pretty soon you know this kind of
thing is starting to churn
And people begin to take what's being said as
gospel truth.
I mean class A uniform,
That's a good one.
Okay,
Everybody knows we have a class A uniform and a
class B and class C, and but there's no such a
thing, not from the standpoint of the Boy Scouts
of America, you know, and I'm pretty safe on this
one.
Okay,
I've looked around and tried to find a
description in any official BSA literature for
a class A uniform, and now there's no such
thing.
Now can you use the term
Sure
If it's useful for you. fine,
If some of the times you want boys wearing
troop T-shirts and you want to call that
class B. you know there's a lot of you
listening now and me for years. hey, we
thought there was a rule book somewhere
with these kind of uniform classes
described in it and you know different
times for us to wear them and it was a
clinker.
So how do we avoid clinkers?
We have to read. you know we can ask
people with some expertise and experience.
There's not these hidden agendas and ulterior
motives, and you know sneaky things that
maybe your district or your council or
national is trying to do, and you know we
have campfires and we stay up late and
we jaw about stuff and we talk about.
you know what we think might be going
on and possibilities, and you know
here's what we really should pledge to
do, and that is to get as much information
as we possibly can before we make big
giant decisions or we make
broad policy statements about stuff.
I end every one of these podcasts by
saying: hey, you know this is me with a
microphone. this is not officialdom
speaking.
I can interview people who are
officials, I can read out official stuff
and everything I have, but that's not to
say that I have the right end of the
stick all the time or that indeed
there is a right end to that
particular stick.
There can be several different ways to
go about things and scouting. that are
perfectly fine
Usually. usually we can be
corrected in a spirit of brotherhood
and kindness. you know it's really no
big problem.
So the next time you hear something
that is lending a little more
heat than light to a situation
next to you, hear something that's
kind of putting the fire out,
consider it could be a clinker.
Get down there, take a look.
Yep,
And we're always here
if you want to discuss it.
Hi, this is Dr Paul Auerbach and
you are listening to Clark Green
on the Scoutmaster podcast.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your
emails.
So I had this email from Shane
Stillwell.
Shane wrote in and said: Clark,
this podcast is partly to credit
or blame for my new position as
Scoutmaster.
Okay, let me explain.
I am a Cubmaster and the father of
three boys.
My oldest son crossed over last
year about this time and I
started to get involved in the
troop.
It didn't take long to realize
that this troop of 25 Scouts was
heavily adult run and didn't
utilize patrols.
When I say adult run, I mean
Scouts weren't even present at
the yearly planning meeting.
They didn't use patrols in the
wise that patrols were formed
right before a weekend outing.
The patrol leader was then
picked by the Scoutmaster and
then the patrol disbanded after
the outing.
Well, I pushed and coaxed and
prodded and suggested the use of
patrols and patrol method in a
boy led troop. after 10 months of
this, with nothing but resistance,
I came to the conclusion that
my vision for scouting was not
all in step with theirs.
To make a long story short,
I helped organize a new troop
and guess what?
I'm the Scoutmaster.
We have 10 boys, only two of
which have any scouting
experience.
If you were in my shoes, what
steps would you take to bring
a new troop full of green Scouts
into a boy led troop?
I know it will take some time
and there's no server bullet.
My biggest fear is that, because
I'm doing much of the instruction
set of precedent, does a new
troop have to be adult led for a
while?
I cannot begin to express in
words the profound impact your
blog and podcast have made on my
life.
You have the talent, wisdom,
insight and experience and I'm
grateful you freely share them.
On more than one occasion you've
challenged my views and won. for
that. I thank you.
Well, thank you, Shane, and thank
you for those kind words.
I'm always glad to hear that
there.
I envy your role in establishing
a new troop.
I've kind of mused about that in
my mind at times, especially
when I'm having trouble with
my own troop-
I think, wow, it'd be great just
to get some boys together and
start all over again.
You know the other thing-
like most things in life, being a
Cubmaster and Scoutmaster and
stuff like that- it's a pretty
involved work and I don't think
we appreciate how big a deal it
really is,
Not only in our lives and in the
lives of the other Scouts, but
especially if you're a dad and
you're able to do this along with
your boys. that's a big, big deal
and something you won't really
realize until you know it's
passed.
Let me see what I can do to help
you out here.
I would say to all of you: any
successful Scoutmaster needs three
basic things:
He needs vision, he needs
perspective and he needs
determination.
He needs a clear understanding of
the aims and methods of Scouting.
and perspective is seeing things
in, measuring progress from a
boy's viewpoint, from a
boy's scale, and determination
is kind of sticking with the
consistent application of the
vision and the
perspective.
I think, Shane, that
you've got the vision-
I mean I'm sure of that-
And I think you have the
determination.
So let's work on the perspective
a little bit.
Maybe that'll help you out.
You probably have
some kind of a really idealized
picture or idea
of a boy-led troop.
Now
I'm saying that because I started
with that kind of
a picture in mind as a young
Scoutmaster.
That picture was based pretty much
on the first edition of the
Patrol Leaders Handbook.
I had a copy of that as a boy.
I was never a Scout as a boy,
but I had that book
And in that book all the boys,
they wore perfect uniforms
and set up perfect campsites.
There were no photographs
in the book, It was just
drawings, right,
And so they were further idealized.
You know, the Patrol Leader said
things like: come on, fellows, I think
this is a great place for a hike.
And that idealized
look at Scouting
really stuck with me And I tried to make it
real as a young Scoutmaster. but
I learned after a few years
that I was missing the forest
for the trees. There was no such thing
as the Patrol. that was in that book.
I was also laboring under
the mishaprehension that a Scoutmaster
was in charge and responsible to instruct
and lead the Scouts. Now
it was really great fun for me to lead.
I had a great time with it
And I learned a lot
And I was happy
and my Scouts were happy and we had a great troop.
I realized, though,
that all the fun and personal growth
I was experiencing as a Scoutmaster
was never really intended for me.
It was intended
for the Scouts. So I stopped
doing what they should be doing
and started helping them do it themselves.
and, long story short, you know
that's the way that it worked.
They weren't doing
things as well as I could-
not by a long shot.
I think the most important aspect
of this perspective
that we're trying to look at
is that quality of instruction,
quality of leadership,
the slickness of the program-
that's not the outcome
of Scouting. If you get
those things, that's a fringe benefit.
Scouting
is the process of boys doing things
that matter.
That's what's really
at the heart of things. When boys
do things, they do things imperfectly
and chaotically from an adult perspective,
but they are doing it,
and that's really what matters.
This is worth repeating.
Boys doing the process
of Scouting is all that really matters.
the quality of their leadership,
their planning and skill
is not what really matters.
I get a fair number of emails from Scout Leaders
who truly want to transition
into a boy led model and think this will take
months and months and I just don't think it's so.
You have a boy led troop
and patrols. when the boys
lead their troop and patrols,
it doesn't matter how well
they lead, it's that they are
in the process of Scouting.
Now this thought
scares the heck out of adults,
especially ones with a troop full of younger Scouts.
They think the process
might work. they try it out
for a few weeks and the results
are so uncertain and chaotic that
they quickly revert to the adult
led version again and they think
the guy online
is crazy.
What they are missing
is that the uncertainty and the chaos
is actually what we want to see.
It's proof that the process
is really happening.
Now you may feel that you
can't put the planning
and instruction and leadership
for your troop
in the hands of your boys,
but you really can
and you really must.
As time goes by you'll see them
get a little better at it and within a few years
you'll be a bit closer to what you've envisioned,
but only through determination
to stick with the vision.
Your tools are coaching and mentoring
and asking lots of questions.
How many times have I said that
You have to fully concentrate
your efforts on asking lots of questions
and train your Scouts in that way
to think for themselves.
Here's an idea.
Here's an illustration.
How would you introduce a bunch of boys to the game of basketball?
Would you sit them all down
and start reading the NCAA rulebook
to them?
Nah, you wouldn't do that.
They wouldn't stand for it, would they?
Now you'd start with the ball
and the basket,
Say: here's a ball, here's a basket.
What happens next? I don't know
How, about putting the ball in the basket? Oh,
They'd try a few shots.
Maybe they'd make some, or maybe they wouldn't,
But they'd be pretty fascinated with the idea, wouldn't they?
And then you could introduce the idea
of dribbling. Hey, you know,
when you walk with the ball, you have to dribble it.
Oh, really, Yeah, that's how it works.
Oh, okay,
Let them try that out for a while.
And after they've been dribbling
and going up and down the court,
they might need to learn a little bit about the double dribble,
about traveling.
You could introduce the idea of two teams
and then rules
for offensive and defensive play.
So what you'd be doing is moving from some
very simple concepts
to more complex ones
Over time.
you'd have a team that could play other teams
that maybe win a game or two,
but it would be a while before they really
understood the game,
Before they really appreciated what was going on.
So
you start a team. it takes a while to get them
to the point where they can play
and they get beat every time.
So here's another piece of perspective.
Why are they playing the game?
Just to pass time? just to learn
something new,
to become, you know, national champions?
No, they're playing the game
because the act of playing itself
is sufficient for them to reap rewards.
They're playing the game
because the act of playing
itself is sufficient for them
to get something out of it.
I mean, at least they're going to get
a little more physically fit.
if they're playing a game of basketball,
Maybe they'll learn a little bit about strategy
and teamwork,
Maybe they'll learn a little bit about leadership.
Playing the game
is in itself
sufficient for them to reap
rewards.
Scouting is exactly the same.
It's not
focused on outdoor skills,
It's not focused on
slick, military-like precision,
It's not focused
on anything but
the process,
And boys who go through the process
of scouting gain advantages
that they may not understand or appreciate
at the time, that their parents
may not understand or appreciate
at the time, but they're going to get
something out of it. Another piece
of that boy perspective
is the amount of information they can
effectively handle at any given time.
Like I said,
I wouldn't teach boys to play basketball
by starting out with the NCAA
Rule Book, which is a pretty
thick book, by the way.
I mean,
you could set up an all-day event
where you're going to read it to them
and maybe you'll make a PowerPoint presentation
and you know,
but they're going to check out
after the first half hour.
No matter how excited and motivated they are,
they're going to check out.
I think the better approach,
especially from the
boy perspective-
short periods of instruction
followed by long periods of hands-on
practice. that seems to
be what works, especially with younger
scouts. So that's a piece
of the perspective that I would encourage you to think about.
So, Shane, let's take all this and we'll
put it in really practical terms. One:
stop leading and instructing,
Just stop doing it.
Number two: ask
your scouts what they want to do next.
Get to your next meeting, say, hey, guys,
you know I had some things planned, but
what would you like to do next?
And
then ask them how they think
that whatever they want to do will
happen. Ask them who will make
it happen. Ask them what they think
you could do to help
them make it happen. maybe Ask
them what they're going to need, ask them how they're
going to plan it. ask, ask, ask,
ask. just keep the questions coming.
Don't talk them to death.
Give them a chance to act and do
what they're going to do. Observe
that and encourage
the least expression of initiative
and skill, Just even the
little glimmer in the dark
of initiative and skill,
and build on those expressions by asking
more questions. Hey, you seem
to be really good at that. You
really know how to do those knots.
Have you learned any new ones lately?
Do you know where you could find out how to
learn more? Have you
taught anybody how to do that? Does
teaching that satisfy any
requirements for any of the ranks
that you're working on?
I mean, once you get into
the habit of asking questions, you're going to find
that it's a very natural thing.
The boys are going to respond to it and they're
going to keep learning. Occasionally
you're going to have to make corrections,
little course corrections, here and there.
You do that by asking more questions.
Guys, what are we up to right now?
How is this benefiting us? How
is this making us good scouts?
Is there something that
you might be doing that might
be more beneficial at this
point in time. Get them to think
about it Now. the determination
to follow this vision
and follow this perspective
in the absence of all evidence that it's
working is important.
I'm laughing, I mean,
because this is
a real key. The determination
to follow your vision
from this perspective
in the absence of all evidence
that it's working is important.
Part of that determination
will come from seeing it
work, and you know you
haven't seen that yet.
So watch for these
small indications from a
boys' perspective, and it'll become
more and more determined as the time
goes by. I hope
that helps, Shane, and
once again, thank you for your kind words.
Thanks for getting in touch. If you'd
like to get in touch if you have a question,
you're going to find out how to do that in just
a moment.
Well, thank you for listening to this
edition of the Scoutmaster podcast. I hope you
enjoyed it. It was intense. Get it
intense. Yeah, we get it
All right, Todd. That's
enough, Thanks. Hey, here's how
you can keep in touch. You can read the Scoutmaster
blog at ScoutmasterCGcom
and there you can subscribe to
receive updates by email. You can
subscribe to this podcast on iTunes
and you can leave a review or a rating there,
and you can also access the
podcast on your mobile device through Stitcher
Smart Radio and you can get the details
of that at Stitchercom.
You can call, just like Todd did. It's a great
experience. It was intense, Get it
All right. Intense,
We get it,
And that number is
234-0002..
You can experience the wonders of ScoutmasterCGcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets. That's
right. You can follow us at ScoutmasterBlog
on Facebook, tweet ScoutmasterCG
on Twitter and,
for admittance to the exclusive ScoutmasterCG
Circle, search for ScoutmasterCG
on Google Plus. and if you
don't do any of that, if you don't face, you don't tweet,
you don't plus- you can email me.
That's right, Bunky, I am
at ScoutmasterCG
at Verizonnet.
I need to remind you of the ScoutmasterBlog
and the Scoutmaster Podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America, nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, once again, it's just me
with a microphone trying to lend a hand to
scout leaders and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
So before we go, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Well, thank you, sir,
Until next time.
It was intense.
Yes,
Are you happy now?